the fate of joe biden's prospective
agenda could come down to one
state georgia democrats are desperate to
win both runoff elections there and
change the balance of power in the
senate
if both senate seats flip blue it could
create a 50-50 split with
vp president-elect kamala harris
being the tiebreaker senator chuck
schumer
very confident about the fight ahead
now we take georgia and then we change
the world
[Music]
now we take georgia and then we change
america
i don't know katie that he might want to
take that one back
he's not going to that's you know he
said the quiet part out loud
uh this georgia it really is going to be
the line that is drawn in the stand you
had mitch mcconnell
put that amazing ad out right before
election day that said hold the line
this is what he was talking about stacey
abrams is obviously
leading the charge in georgia to get
these two democrats elected she's raised
six million dollars already at this
point
people are dumping a lot of money into
that state now given how democrats spent
so much money in other southern states
like south carolina
they may not win as a result however if
it all comes down to georgia it depends
you know if if the republicans take it
joe biden will have a very different
presidency than if he has democrats in
charge
if democrats are in charge of the senate
there are no stoppages for republicans
in the far left agenda if the
republicans keep it joe biden can
actually
live up to his calls for unity and
working with republicans but if
democrats take the senate you have
people like chuck schumer saying they
want to change america
that means that far left list that
republicans and president trump were
warning about leading into this election
will be able to get right through and
the cabinet will look much different
depending on who
wins uh that those senate races as well
millions of dollars juan
pouring into georgia from outside
special interests
you don't want all that money do you if
i was a finance if i was a political
consultant i'd get in that business my
goodness that race is going to be ugly
it's going to be expensive
yep uh i do think it's going to be very
interesting because joe biden won
georgia
and with joe biden winning georgia it
tells you about the chance that in fact
democrats could win
both of those senators are they
recounting georgia i don't know
yes i don't know georgia uh because i
think you have to hit a cut-off point so
i don't know if that has been officially
enough
but i do know this that the republican
lieutenant
governor of georgia said there was no
evidence of any credible voter fraud
and i think that's going to be more
determined there yeah there's a big
recount there so it's perfectly
reasonable i think to conclude
that democrats have a chance and i also
think because there's going to be
less turnout with trump not on the
ballot again the get out the vote
efforts led by stacey abrams and others
has a better chance of paying off and i
do think that if tillis holds on
in north carolina then you have a chance
to have what the scenario you described
with kamala harris as the tiebreaker it
looks like tillis is going to be holding
on uh would you like to make
a prediction in the georgia senate
runoff
you're good at this dana i am so good at
this um i
i do my gut instinct is that the
republicans can win
i think that message is better than
money and i do think there'll be plenty
of money though if you're a
if you're a big democrat donor and they
call you up and say hey can you
throw us a million dollars like why you
didn't win any of those senate races
why would i do that but they but they
have a lot of grassroots money and i
think we have to
have take a second here to say stacy
abrams she did a good job right so she
never conceded the governor's race but
she obviously lost but she then
dedicated the next two years
to figuring out a way how to get turnout
of democrats in georgia
and her operation was really good so the
democrats the republicans have their
work cut out for them
but i think that line that schumer said
i said yesterday on fox news sunday he's
he sounds more like don quixote than
general sherman
who's going to take georgia and then
america but the message matters
and one of the things that the
republicans will say is if
the republicans do not win guess who's
the senate budget chairman
bernie sanders oh that means there is
actually a socialist exactly
right greg i think joe
should hope that the democrats lose
because he needs to have a supplemental
backbone
he needs to have a he needs to have a
bad cop there
and an excuse and we and america needs
it because we need adults in the room
you can't have a whole
single political party government
america loves a divided
government because it guarantees that
there will be
debate and i'm for polarization i want
two sides
i i mean everybody's upset about
polarization think about the odd
the alternative one pole two poles are
better
so the reason why trump won in 2016
is because the center refused for
decades to stand up to the left right
the regressive left
and trump understood that america was
sick and tired of groupthink of
left-wing groupthink
if you don't if the dems don't
understand this and if
if they and you have a left a left-wing
house a left-wing senate and a liberal
spineless president you're going to see
something even bigger than trump in 2022
and 2024.
yeah well i think didn't republicans
have control of the house the senate and
the white house
after 16. i didn't hear you say that
then we're only you know polarization in
this instance
we're listening